the opening scene to doctor strange and
a multiverse of madness has been shown
behind scenes and i'm going to give you
a description breakdown of it but before
we get into it i'm going to give a
spoiler warning as this covers about the
first 20 minutes of the film without the
way let's get straight into it so the
movie opens with a demon chase in
america chavez and defender strange who
ends up getting killed but america
chavez manages to escape to our mcu cut
to doctor strange waking up and thinking
it was all a dream he then goes to
christine's wedding where he's
confronted about the blip and his role
in what happened by michael strawberg
was there really only one way to beat
thanos strange and christine talk at the
bar he regrets not making her a priority
she wants to introduce him to her
husband strange is then interrupted by
gangantos arriving in downtown new york
strange leaps into action and chavrez
and wong join him all three team up to
battleground gantos together in a magic
field fight after gagantos was defeated
they had to get some food where america
chavez introduces herself until she's
being hunted there's a funny bit where
doctor strange explains spider-man to
her who apparently doesn't exist in her
home universe the main goal seems to be
to find the book of reshanti which wong
knows exists because he's a sorcerer
supreme taking a dig at his power soon
come to realize it's witchcraft and they
need more help so strange seeks out
wonder wonder is also having dreams
which is having dreams of her kids one
division flashback but basically no
vision she wakes up and is sad before
she goes to her field to cut the trees
she and strange talk about the
multiverse and he asked for her help so
this is the end of the footage
description as i said before this takes
up about the first 20 minutes of the
film and already in the first 20 minutes
we have covered so much in such little
time i remember people a bit worried
that the film was too short and they
wanted a much longer film but hearing
the pacing of this film and what was
covered in the first 20 minutes it seems
like it's going to be a very very
fast-paced film so i feel like no time
is going to be wasted i feel like sam
romy's knowing what he's doing so i'm
not concerned about the length of the
film at all also i remember hearing
there was going to be a spider-man
reference in this movie and it seems
like this reference will be getting in
the first 20 minutes where america
chavrez wong and dr strange are having
lunch together i don't believe we'll get
a cameo from spider-man but who knows i
could be wrong so i guess only time will
tell but anyway that pretty much covers
everything for this video so let me know
in the comment section below what you
thought of the opening scene and if you
haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on to
show your support thanks for watching